we are really getting very close to the
2022 midterm elections and what I want
to do is take a look at some of the most
important races potentially what we
might call Bellwether races also
potentially difference making races as
far as the U.S Senate is concerned see
where things are and talk about where we
go from here now a little bit later on
in the program many of you dozens and
dozens of you emailing me over the
weekend about so many of the incredible
debates that took place over this
weekend Marjorie Taylor green debating
her opponent Marcus flowers Herschel
Walker debating Rafael Warnock Ron
Johnson debating Mandela Barnes Kerry
Lake
in a very strange CNN interview about
whether or not she would accept the
results we're going to look at all of
that but to first set the stage let's
take a look at some of what I consider
to be the most important races either
because
they could be the Difference Maker in
who controls the senate or because they
have some other particular importance
like the Pennsylvania gubernatorial
election now
I know people are going to email and say
but David sir you missed this race or
you missed that race and it's so
important I can't look at every race I'm
also not looking at any Congressional
races in this segment because it's it's
very unlikely that the Congressional
balance will depend on one seat and so
there's just so many congressional races
to look at that I'm not doing that right
now but let's just start going down the
list and see where these races stand
first and foremost Pennsylvania Governor
Pennsylvania Governor matters so much
because when you look at swing States
for a presidential election and then you
look at which of the Swing States could
be the sole Difference Maker and who
becomes the next president of the United
States Pennsylvania is at or near the
top of that list and Doug mastriano the
Republican candidate in Pennsylvania is
openly running
on a big lie campaign platform if given
the opportunity if Doug mastriano is the
governor of Pennsylvania in 2024 he gets
to choose the secretary of state which
oversees the election and he will pick
someone who would be willing to just
straight up try to steal Pennsylvania's
electoral votes if a Democrat wins and
they don't like it they will try to
steal it for the Republican this is an
extraordinarily important race the good
news here
is that Josh Shapiro the Democratic
candidate is winning by an average of 10
points that is a significant lead I'm
not going to say this after every one of
these races but assume nothing everyone
must vote this is just a reflection of
where the polling today is best based on
the best data we have there's still time
things can depart from the polling but
this one so far is looking pretty good
Josh Shapiro there's very little to say
about Josh Shapiro because he's so
uncontroversial some might say he's milk
toast others will say he's just a
completely normal person who isn't going
to try to steal any elections this one
is looking good
and we really have to hope that Josh
Shapiro does win also in Pennsylvania is
the Senate race the senate race is
television Dr Mehmet Oz against the
lieutenant governor John fetterman Oz is
the Republican fetterman is the Democrat
John fetterman had a stroke months ago
there is now a big campaign in which
Oz's campaign is participating even if
Oz himself is less overtly participating
in it to basically say because of the
stroke fetterman can't be a senator we
already addressed that last week in
quite a bit of detail the good news here
is that fetterman's winning the bad news
here is that fetterman isn't winning by
that much right now it's about a three
and a half Point margin on average for
fetterman in recent polling Pennsylvania
is maybe the most important state in the
midterms both because of it's the senate
race and it's the gubernatorial our
friends in Pennsylvania
I hope every single one of you is
planning to vote
Florida Florida has a very interesting
Senate race and again the Senate may
come down to just one seat so every one
of these big Senate races is important
incumbent Republican Marco Rubio kind of
a pathetic character there's just
something about him that's very pathetic
key in a bad way not in the old
philosophical sense he is facing a
challenge from congresswoman Val demings
on the Democratic side
it's not looking great for Val demings
but this is still potentially winnable
Rubio is up by somewhere between four
and five points we will be carrying the
debate between Rubio and demings
you know it might have been rescheduled
so it might be tomorrow it might be
later on in the month anyway when it
happens if it does I will carry it
Florida voters you've got an important
race there as well also in Florida is
the gubernatorial race and again when we
think about I mean listen think about
Florida Florida
could be the Difference Maker and who
becomes president in 2024 but moreover
the guy who wants to be re-elected as
Governor Ron DeSantis may end up being
the Republican Presidential nominee in
2024 so this one is doubly important and
as I've said before it's not looking
good for Charlie Chris the Democratic
Challenger Ron DeSantis has a
comfortable lead of just under eight
points that will be difficult to
overcome but listen all of our Florida
viewers should be voting regardless
because of that Senate race so when
you're there you vote for governor we
try to get Ron DeSantis out even though
it is an uphill battle then we go to
North Carolina this one has not gotten
that much attention but it really should
because it's so close Sherry Beasley is
the Democratic nominee
um Ted bud is the Republican nominee
it's almost a tie okay if you look at
the only polling from the last
month okay it's a tie and the Republican
plus one and on average including
earlier polling Real Clear Politics has
this as a one and a half point lead for
Ted Budd let's not sleep on North
Carolina and I know there's the
Assumption in North Carolina the
undecideds are going to turn out for the
Republican and all the different things
what what better thing do we have to do
than vote okay let's just let's vote and
let's see where we get but that's a race
not getting as much attention and it
really should North Carolina you can
vote for Sherry Beasley then we go to
Wisconsin Wisconsin
I'll be honest
I don't really know
exactly where this race is going right
now because there was an absolutely
humiliating debate over the weekend
where the incumbent Republican Senator
Ron Johnson was booed
he was openly laughed at and he bombed
in his debate against Challenger Mandela
Barnes who by the way Mandela Barnes has
been a guest on this program you can go
check out in the archives on YouTube or
on our website my interview with Mandela
Barnes super smart guy
um Barnes crushed the debate so all of
the polling I have is at least eight
days old it has Johnson leading by just
under three points even if that's the
case today that Johnson is leading by
about three points this one is possible
and the disastrous debate performance
for Johnson over the weekend may hurt
him further so this is a very important
race this is a possible seat that can be
taken from Republicans then of course we
have the State of Arizona two important
races there we covered the Arizona
Senate debate that's incumbent Democrat
Mark Kelly challenged by Maga trumpist
Blake Masters Blake Masters is horrible
and dishonest and unethical and just
vile a gross gross guy he uh scrubbed
all of the violently anti abortion stuff
from his website after the primary but
now is kind of trying to explain it away
and he can't he is a big lie proponent
although he downplayed that during the
debate a week and a half ago with Mark
Kelly right now the good news is Kelly
is up four and a half
the bad news is Kelly should be up 40.
but Kelly was not particularly good in
the debate Kelly is not like an electric
exciting guy
um so if you vote in Arizona not only do
you have this Senate race but you also
have maybe even more disturbingly the
Arizona gubernatorial race in Arizona
the incumbent Governor Doug Ducey is
leaving and there is an open seat the
Democratic nominee is Katie Hobbs the
Republican nominee is one of the most
aggressively weaponized from a
disinformation big lie standpoint
candidates Carrie Lake she is Trump
endorsed she is Trump loved right now
it pains me to say this Kerry lake is
winning by just under one point
and the last two polls that were done an
Insider Advantage poll and an ohpi poll
each has Lake ahead by three
Kerry lake is a lunatic
again it's sort of like if Herschel
Walker were to win if Kerry Lake wins it
is another serious humiliation for the
United States our Arizona viewers
you in Pennsylvania
you've got a lot on your shoulders here
we really have to do everything we can
to prevent Kerry Lake from winning we
then have in Ohio
uh JP Mandel right no JD Vance versus
Tim Ryan
Tim Ryan is not the best candidate his
debate performance was not
exactly beautiful
but JD Vance is a trump ass kisser
exactly the way that Tim Ryan described
him in the last debate and sadly JD
Vance is winning by just under one point
and the polling seems to be moving in
Vance's favor if you vote in Ohio this
is a big one
and then lastly in Georgia
uh uh we have oh I've got to do the
Herschel Walker one as well second to
last the state of Georgia uh it's
incumbent Republican Brian Kemp versus
Challenger Stacy Abrams Stacy Abrams is
extraordinary Kemp is horrible and Kemp
is winning by five okay so our Georgia
voters many many
extraordinarily important races for you
and let me just get the Walker Warnock
numbers up as well because those are so
important in the Walker Warnock race and
we will get to their debate a little bit
later Raphael Warnock is up by a hair
over three points but Herschel Walker is
gaining on him
so Georgia
um I and I know I didn't do Texas
Georgia Pennsylvania and Arizona
multiple important races I hope
everybody there is voting we'll get to
the debates later in the show last week
the January 6th house committee
investigating the Trump riots voted to
subpoena the failed former president
himself
is he going to show up almost certainly
not are the best legal assessments
Trump's reaction was to send a
delusional
14-page letter including pictures of the
crowd on January 6th why on Earth would
you want to point fingers at that Donald
Trump was investigated and subpoenaed
everything's legal everything's kosher
every eye is crossed and T dotted to
quote Sean Hannity
and Trump flipped out peacefully and
patriotically he calls this letter and
he writes to the chairman of the January
6 committee Benny Thompson the same oh
sorry the presidential election of 2020
was rigged and stolen the same group of
radical left Democrats who utilized
their capital M majority position in
Congress to create the fiction of Russia
Russia Russia impeachment hoax number
one impeachment hoax number two the 48
million dollar Mueller report which
ended in no collusion Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine the atrocious and illegally
capital S spying on my capital c
campaign and so much more are the people
who created this Committee of Highly
partisan political Capital H hacks and
capital T thugs
whose sole function is to destroy the
lives of many hard-working American
Patriots whose records in life have been
unblemished until this point of
attempted ruination
folks that's one sentence and I'm
already out of breath
um this goes on and on and on and it is
delusional and it blames antifa and it
blames black lives matter and it talks
about Trump
um uh having Time magazine covers and
stories and it's absolutely Bonkers and
I encourage you to read all of it it
includes such lines as since 1888 no
incumbent president has gained votes and
lost re-election
okay that doesn't really tell us
anything Trump says we swept all four
Bellwether States Iowa Florida Ohio and
North Carolina and they have correctly
predicted election winners since 1896.
Trump using a lot of what we don't
actually call evidence that he won
it's not evidence that he won and then
he even goes on later in this completely
delusional letter
uh and by the way it's riddled with lies
like he tried to get the National Guard
out on January 6th there's no evidence
of that none whatsoever he goes on to
talk about
um he presents evidence from Wisconsin
which we will get to Trump includes an
appendix in the letter which has an
image of Washington DC I guess on
January 6th
I don't know why you would call
attention to that because your followers
rioted and committed hundreds of crimes
many pictures and then he starts talking
about Arizona
and Maricopa County including lots of
debunked claims that there were
mismatched signatures and that there was
fraud and Auditors found this that and
the other thing he also cites Dr Shiva
who's a completely conspiratorial nut
job it's completely Bonkers and when you
actually take each of these claims and
investigate them you say okay well let's
look at Arizona what actually happened
in Arizona you look at Arizona and you
find that almost every single one of
these claims every claim is either an
outright lie or an exaggeration
that the numbers were looked at the uh
what are called overvotes were actually
less significant in 2020 than in Prior
elections you look at every single one
of the lawsuits that was brought in
Arizona and you find that some were
voluntarily dismissed for example the
Aguilera V Fontes lawsuit known as the
original Sharpie lawsuit it was
voluntarily dismissed the second suit
brought by Aguilera alleging oh my vote
wasn't counted I want to cast a new
ballot it was dismissed with prejudice
on the merits it was not an issue of
standing as many people like Mike pillow
like to claim you just look through all
the lawsuits and you see every single
one of these claims Trump makes was
either so baseless that it didn't go
anywhere or it was evaluated by a court
and it was dismissed with prejudice in
many of these cases it is a delusional
letter he goes on to talk about Georgia
we've looked at Georgia extensively
these claims are not accurate just to
pick one random one of these things
Trump writes at least 10 300 illegally
cast votes in Georgia maybe 35
000 are from individuals who voted in
the wrong County more than necessary to
tip the 20 or 2020 results remember some
of the people that voted in the wrong
County what happened is they moved they
moved they were registered in two places
as is common as long as you only vote in
one place and you were legally
registered there you're fine also look
at this margin of error somewhere
between 10 and 35
000 such votes
um it's all lies and you can page
through it it goes on eventually to talk
about Michigan we've talked about
Michigan endlessly Pennsylvania has
maybe looked at more been looked at more
closely than any other state Wisconsin
and this is really a Gish Gallop of
outrageous proportions Trump so
triggered by The subpoena that he sends
a 14-page letter riddled with lies and
pictures in response now Will trump
actually respond to the subpoena and
show up to testify before the January
6th committee
almost certainly not we're linking to
two articles one from NPR called so
Donald Trump has been subpoenaed here's
what comes next the other article from
the law fair blog Trump responds to
January 6 committee subpoena almost
certainly Trump will not be showing up
to testify and then the question becomes
what happens next these articles tell
you we'll link to them we'll talk about
them tomorrow in the meantime you can
find me on Twitter at dpacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show continues to be a
viewer listener and Community funded
program I would love for you to sign up
on my website joinpakman.com where you
can get access to the Daily bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show we're down to
the end folks and you can use the coupon
code big voting22 to get yourself a
discount it's cheap it's quick the money
goes directly into our operation and you
get some great perks you can sign up at
joinpakman.com coupon code big voting
22. the last 48 hours have been some of
the most overtly anti-semitic in the
American Media space than I can remember
in a very long time a little bit later
we're going to get to one of the most
insane anti-semitic rants I've seen
Short of actual Nazis and it came from
Kanye West that's after but first we
have to talk about failed former
president Donald Trump
seemingly cracking in an authoritarian
fascistic tirade against Jews not only
attacking American Jews but warning
American Jews you'd better appreciate
what I've done for you or things could
get very bad a typical anti-semitic
fascistic tirade which I'm going to
explain to you Donald Trump went on his
platform truth Central known to some as
truth social and Donald Trump said The
Following over the weekend and I do
quote no president has done more for
Israel than I have somewhat surprisingly
however our wonderful evangelicals are
far more appreciative of this than the
people of the Jewish faith especially
those living in the U.S those living in
Israel though are a different story
highest approval rating in the world by
the way not true
could easily be prime minister U.S Jews
have to get their act together and
appreciate what they have in Israel and
here's the warning before it is too late
this is truly disgusting disgusting now
first before we get into explaining the
layers of anti-Semitism here just a sort
of reality
the Evangelical love for Israel and thus
support for Republican presidents on
that issue
has nothing to do with Judaism
and it has nothing to do with Jews the
Evangelical love for Israel relates
primarily to their biblical belief that
if they support Israel it will
accelerate the second coming of Jesus
Christ and implicit in that depending on
which version of Christianity you
believe or follow there is a Rapture
apocalypse the Jews eventually do die in
some versions of the story all the Jews
other than 144 000 of them die
it's Bonkers and so you should judge the
Evangelical support for Israel
as an example of complete and utter
religious Insanity it has nothing to do
with what Jews Like Me actually care
about or are concerned with that's
number one okay now what Donald Trump
says here
is sadly a classic from the anti-semitic
tropes of History why aren't Jews more
grateful to me for something I did for
them that is a classic classic
anti-semitic Trope when Jews don't
accept the leader's cult or the cult's
leader whichever way you want to say it
they are seen as implicitly undermining
the leader and they are bad and maybe
they even need to be punished for that
then there's also the horribly
anti-semitic idea of the good Jews
versus the bad ones out in the diaspora
when we talk about the Jewish diaspora
we mean Jews around the world and I know
a lot of this stuff is new to some in
our audience and and maybe unfamiliar
but that's why we're talking about it
this is a classic this is a classic here
are the good Jews right the ones either
staying within their schedules or
ghettos or whatever and then sometimes
if it's right-wingers the good Jews in
Israel and then the bad Jews of the
diaspora those bad liberal Jews in the
United States and the UK and France and
okay on and on and on and then of course
there's also the threat there
that's the other part of it get your act
together because you know people have
come after Jews in the past
things have gotten pretty bad for Jews
historically in the past you'd better
get your act together and appreciate
Trump before it is too late and bad
things start to happen if you don't
appreciate me
now once you get beyond the
anti-Semitism you also realize that
Trump as well as many others have
absolutely no understanding of the
reality of Jews in the United States as
a community with interests and
priorities that are very different than
those of Jews living in Israel for
example and this goes back to the Dual
loyalty anti-semitic Trope there's this
idea that okay listen if you uh if your
parents or grandparents came to the U.S
from Italy
or from Germany or from Portugal there
is not this thing that follows you
around about
you might still have loyalty to Portugal
if it came down to it do you choose the
U.S or do you choose Portugal or
whatever the case may be and with Jews
even Jews who have never been to Israel
there is this idea of dual loyalty well
I don't know here's what's good for the
U.S and here's maybe what's good for
Israel and these American Jews can't
really be trusted because they they have
a loyalty to Israel that might override
most Jews have never even been to Israel
don't even follow the the politics of
Israel internal or foreign policy
understand that anti-Semitism while
proclaiming that you love Israel is a
standard of the Evangelical right
and it's definitely a standard of Maga
so a disgusting comment from Trump but
nothing compared to Kanye West
I have never seen anything like what I
am about to play for you
Kanye West went on something called
drink Champs
and delivered one of the most
anti-Semitic rants against the Jewish
people that I have ever seen in the sort
of modern media era short of actual
Nazis and it's basically there Kanye
West in controversy lately I won't go
through the entire thing he's a musical
artist he was recently wearing white
lives matter gear and then he went on
the Tucker Carlson show and said a whole
bunch of stuff including anti-semitic
stuff which got cut out but which we
ultimately obtained and looked at last
week
let's go through this and I'm telling
you
I have I have not seen anything like
this in the modern era short of from
over white supremacist Nazis let's just
jump right in and I will stop it and
talk about some of the things he says uh
we made the white lives matter tease and
then when I put up the the Tweet the
Defcon tweet nah he ain't he ain't
releasing the teeth because he's Jewish
and I'm like see this is my exact point
that I'm making like Jewish people have
owned the black voice what Jewish people
have owned the black boys you know it's
interesting because Kanye's recent thing
over the last few years has been black
folks have no one to blame but ourselves
for slavery which is like a crazy thing
to say but now all of a sudden he's
actually found something better his
first thing was black folks we should
just blame ourselves for everything bad
now he's actually saying oh you know
it's Jews let's blame Jews
um the truth is Jewish folks have been
one of the Premier partners for black
folks in the United States
to demand and obtain quality rights
self-determination Jewish folks have
been killed in fact depend defending and
supporting black folks remember the
movie Mississippi Burning but the
murders of black rights activists in
Mississippi
sometimes people see the names and they
get confused because the victims were
James Chaney and Andrew Goodman and
Michael schwerner and people will look
at that and say Goodman and schwerner
those aren't exactly typical black names
that's right they were Jewish men from
New York City because the uh Jewish
activists were so intertwined with the
Civil Rights Movement the history is so
intertwined Kanye is way off track now
let's continue whether it's through US
wearing a Ralph Lauren
shirt okay
Ralph Lauren shirts
so I realize that for me all this stuff
I'm familiar with every one of these
things but for a lot of people they
don't know what Ralph Lauren what do you
mean why Ralph Lauren Ralph Lauren the
designer was born Ralph lifshitz a
Jewish guy from New York City
so
Kanye says wearing Ralph Lauren it's
another way in which Jews are
controlling us well why not Tommy
Hilfiger I mean black folks like other
people also wear Tommy Hilfiger well
Tommy Hilfiger is Jewish so it's not
interesting to Kanye Ralph Lauren is
Jewish so that is more interesting or as
all of us being signed to a record label
or having a Jewish manager or being
assigned to a Jewish basketball team
what is a Jewish basketball team
he doesn't mean an Israeli I mean
there's an Israeli professional
basketball league that's not what he
means does he mean a team where the
owner is Jewish or the general manager
or what what is his Jewish basketball
team and you know there is this for
people who care about this stuff there
is a very important historical story
about how Jews were pushed into certain
professions there were all sorts of
Industries in which Jews were just not
allowed to participate and what happened
was there was a period where the
industry's Jews were allowed to
participate in were the ones wherein the
the sort of learning and training could
kind of happen on your own like a bunch
of a bunch of Jews not allowed to do a
whole bunch of other stuff they could
get together and talk about you know
whatever is it the law is it what
whatever and so the very discrimination
against Jews created an environment in
which Jews were pushed towards certain
industries The Conspiracy to control
those Industries is where it gets
completely anti-semitic but there is a
discrimination history that talks about
and explains why you saw Jews push
towards certain industries anyway this
stuff is really nuts or doing a movie on
a Jewish platform like Disney okay what
is a Jewish platform like Disney Walt
Disney
was not only not Jewish he had a
reputation for being very anti-semitic
Walt Disney so I don't know how it's now
a Jewish platform like the current
president of Disney is Bob chapek maybe
he's Jewish I don't know I don't know
whether Kanye knows that
uh it's it's really nuts and we
understand it's like I I respect what
the Jew Jewish people have done and what
have they done and they brought their
people together you know they came into
money uh through the lawyers oh boy
oh boy when uh after Wall Street when um
what does that mean after Wall Street
when all of the uh like the Catholics
they wouldn't they wouldn't divorce
people so that's truly bongers
Jewish lawyers came into money by
divorcing people when the Catholics
wouldn't I found no evidence of that so
the Jewish lawyers came and they were
willing to divorce people that's when
they first came into their money so like
say with me and Jay with our our culture
with the with the darker juice first of
all because it happens when anybody
starts talking deep okay yeah yeah with
the dark with the darker Jews the 12
lost tribes of Israel so remember I
explained this last week this is the
black Israelite stuff black Israelites
are a group that believe they are truly
the Jews
um it's often a very racist set of
beliefs we are because we Jewish also
we're from Africa also we're the blood
of Christ so now if you're confused by
that last line it's Bonkers I won't even
get into it and that's just black we are
Jew just like the Jewish people and now
we're coming into money but the main
thing is I got a drink to do say over
the Hennessy as the first step to us
coming together like how the Jewish
people came together but we couldn't
even talk about I remember Ben Horowitz
called me after 444 said I don't know
about Jay giving up business Jewish
business secrets and these secrets okay
Ben Ben Horowitz I oh I mean listen
there's no evidence that that happened I
guess it's hard to comment on something
so insane please talk about um building
up uh the properties and stuff like that
yeah these secrets can't they not fit
what he's arguing is that Ben Horowitz
who's a venture capitalist and Jewish
presumably because his last name is
Horowitz I'm assuming he's saying he
called up Jay-Z when Jay-Z was starting
I guess to make investments in real
estate I assume by Jay he means Jay-Z
and told him that's a Jewish Business
secret right buying real estate that's
that's a secret I have never seen
anything like this I have never seen
anything like this and you can of course
say oh it's it's simply mental illness
well sure I mean it sounds mentally ill
in a lot of different ways
but he has become fixated with Jews in a
way that is reminiscent of the worst of
the worst of the worst anti-semites we
will have that clip on our Instagram at
davidpackman show hard to find a true
word in that segment
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
I know many of you have been anxiously
waiting for the clips from the Herschel
Walker debate and the clips from the
Marjorie Taylor green debate let's get
right into it finally finally Georgia
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker agreed to do a debate with the
incumbent Democratic senator Rafael
Warnock now Herschel Walker humiliated
himself during this debate not only with
unintelligible word salads but also by
pulling out a fake police badge in a way
that is historic Rick Saturday Night
Live can't even do anything with it
because how do you make a parody of
something that looks like a parody but
also Raphael Warnock didn't do
particularly well he didn't come across
as particularly passionate he didn't
come across as particularly prepared and
he refused presumably deciding that he
was not actually going to destroy Walker
for his incredible hypocrisies and
incompetence and maybe he thought it
would look better to play it a little
more polite I don't know and we will
talk about it here is the incredible
moment in which Raphael Warnock pointed
out that Herschel Walker has pretended
to be a police officer and Herschel
Walker pulls out a fake badge and then
is admonished by the uh debate moderator
almost like he's a little kid
one thing I have not done I've never
pretended to be a police officer
and and and I've never I've never
threatened a shootout with the police
yeah and now I have to respond to that
we are moving on gentlemen respond to
that and you know what's so funny I am
with minute police officers so he pulled
out a badge there for those of you who
couldn't see and at the same time Mr
Walker Mr Walker Mr Walker Mr Walker
excuse me Mr Walker
I need to let you know Mr Walker you are
very well aware of the rules tonight yes
and you have a prop that is not allowed
sir I ask you to put that prop away well
it's not a problem this is real
and of course she means a prop in the
sense of the debate that they have an
item and he said I have a problem
Mr Walker excuse me sir yes you're very
well aware of the rules aren't you well
are you aware if you brought up the
truth let's talk about the truth thank
you so listen
nobody will ever actually respond like
you asked the Walker campaign to provide
proof or whatever there's never any
explanation as to what that is every
indication is that it's either straight
up a fake badge or what would be a real
honorary badge an honorary badge is
nothing you don't flash it and an
honorary badge has no law enforcement
meaning or authority behind it it's just
something you sometimes get if you do
like a ride along or a walk through of
some kind with police
um he also after the debate claimed that
he trained with the FBI and this I mean
it's kafka-esque the the interviewer
looks very closely at the badge so when
I mentioned the FBI you know people know
I was joking but I have trained with FBI
like I was joking but he did actually
mention with the FBI FBI you know people
know I was joking but I have trained
with FBI I have supported men and women
in blue for years this is not so this is
what you were saying I'm not this is not
something that I doctors having to do so
they lied about it so so this is this
was Johnson County Herschel Walker
that's not just one I have many of bags
that I worked with Lauren he has many
badges now I have to tell you guys all
of this stuff is meaningless like
civilians don't train with the FBI
there's not even any meaning to that
they don't have any professional
certification they can't act in any way
sometimes the FBI does What's called the
familiarization when you've got an
influential member of the public where
you like you might do an obstacle course
or something like that you go to a
shooting range it's not training at all
and the idea that it connects to
carrying a badge in any way is just
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous now
let's get into some kind of substance
even though it wasn't very substantive
the moderators asked Herschel Walker
what is one idea you have a specific
idea to reduce inflation he just gives a
word salad you've been openly critical
blaming President Biden and the
Democrats for inflation and for the
economy if elected what is one idea one
idea that you would Champion to reduce
inflation we ask you to be specific you
have 60 seconds good luck well first of
all you have to blame this
Administration and Senator or not
because within two years this inflation
has gotten worse they are cut and of
course it's gotten worse all over the
world
and it doesn't seem to have anything to
do with Raphael Warnock our energy uh
Independence they also raise taxes now
neither of those things are true
you look at oil exports and imports and
the trade balance has not changed
dramatically since Trump left there has
not been a tax increase and at the same
time the Reckless spending all our money
so he will sit here tonight and say that
he's doing a good job for us and you
asked me what is one job I would do to
help the inflation first of all we've
got to become independent or energy
independent again and the reason why
they are we're going to our enemies to
ask for gas and oil and that puts us not
just in a inflation problem but it put
us on a national security problem and I
think that's something that I think
Senator Warner need to realize and he
mentioned that he grew up here in
Savannah all right so he doesn't give an
answer he doesn't that there's no actual
answer to the question then in another
completely unintelligible moment
Herschel Walker says Americans have to
get off of Government Health Care
and get on the health care that Raphael
Warnock has which is of course
government health care because if you
have an able-bodied job you're going to
have health care but everyone else have
health care is the type of health care
you're going to get and I think that is
the problem and what Senator Warner want
you to do is depend on the government
what I want you to do is get off the
government health care and get on the
health care he's got right get you a
better health care yeah a government
plan that's that's what's fascinating so
that's what I'm trying to do to make you
independent yep Herschel Walker will
make you independent on Health Care by
getting you off of Government health
care and getting you on government
health care which will make you
independent of the government it's
pretty interesting then here is Walker's
rhetoric on abortion and again when he
is asked about this incredible double
standard wherein he claims to be against
abortion but also a paid for an abortion
and urged the same woman to get a second
abortion it's all totally incoherent
regardless of who wins in November will
you accept
thank you very much gentlemen Buck over
to you thank you Tina we turn now to the
topic of abortion we're going to start
with you Mr Walker a week before this
debate a former girlfriend made public
accusation saying you paid for an
abortion and that you encouraged her to
have another in an ABC news interview
this week you said that the accusations
are quote all lies for the voters
watching tonight can you explain the
circumstances surrounding these claims
you have 60 seconds well as I said
that's a lie and you know what most
thing I put I put it in a book one thing
about my life is I've been very
transparent not like the senator he's
here things but at the same time I said
that's a lie and on abortion you know
I'm a Christian I believe in life right
but you paid for the abortion and I tell
people this Georgia is a state that
respects life and I'll be a senator that
protects life and I say that was a lie
and I'm not backing down and we have
Senator Warner people that would do
anything and say anything for this seat
but I'm not gonna back down because back
down from what see it's too important to
the Georgia people for me to back down
right now
you've been vocally pro-life supporting
a ban on abortions without exceptions
would you support a complete ban on a
national level that's not true either I
say I support uh a heartbeat bill
and I say I support the Georgia
heartbeat bill because that's the bill
of the people from Governor Kim what
that has exceptions in it I said I'm a
Christian but I'm also representing the
people of Georgia and that's who I
represent so yeah so just continuing to
say that what appears to be an obviously
true story about him paying for the
abortion and urging a second one isn't
real but he won't actually engage with
the merits of it which is this is the
mother of one of your kids right yes
okay so and you were at one point in a
relationship with it right yes are you
denying she ever got pregnant or what
like if it was actually subjected to
some questioning it would almost
certainly fall apart now two other notes
on this the moderation in this debate
was a disaster
they gave easier questions to Herschel
Walker presumably because they
understood he couldn't handle tougher
questions but also Raphael Warnock did
not do well and I wouldn't be shocked
Walker didn't fall apart partially
because Warnock didn't bring the heat
and so it wouldn't shock me for the race
to get closer after the debate rather
than actually further apart so
disappointed in Raphael warnock's
performance Walkers was of course a
total disaster next debate that we
looked at Marjorie Taylor green versus
Challenger Marcus flowers this one is
like nothing I have ever ever seen first
and foremost Marjorie Taylor green
accuses one of the journalists on the
panel of being a Democrat activist
so-called because of a question he asked
take a look at this and we need to what
can you tell me give me an example no
you do this every time we have a debate
where you at I ask a a question that's
obvious and you're like what you mean
you were kicked off with your committees
for saying things were controversial
you've apologized for controversial
statements right those types of things
what is your process for fact checking
and vetting the things that you say in
public I the the things I I say in
public are the truth and that's why
they're so offensive to Democrat
activists in the media just like you
notice how that's not an answer that's
not well here's how I fact check no it's
you're a Democrat activist for even
asking them and you're asking me a
blanket question with no example I stand
by the things that I say I stand by
saying she stands by It Whatever It Is
she stands by it and of course she said
some horrible things a Marjorie Taylor
green flips out when her opponent Marcus
flowers accuses her of fomenting the
sentiment that led to January 6 by
pushing election big lie stuff and then
he tries to pin her down as to whether
Joe Biden won she refuses to answer she
says only that Joe Biden is the
president this is really embarrassing to
almost to a person
has said Marjorie Taylor green is not
who they want representing them
so yes this campaign is about Marcus
flowers
not not MTG thank you Josh I'd need a
rebuttal to that uh you cannot accuse me
of insurrection I was a victim of the
January 6 Riot just as much as any other
member of Congress that was the third
day I had on the job I had nothing to do
with what happened there that day and I
will not have you accuse me of that that
is wrong of you to do you're lying about
me and you will not defame my character
in that manner did Joe Biden win the
election congresswoman green Joe Biden
is the president of the United States
understand that that's how they avoid it
they say he is the president but they
won't say he won absolutely but you
pushed a big lie that said he did not
win the election
I drove those people to the Capitol on
January 6.
we're going to move on Joshua and my
question
my husband has proof that's another one
of the lies she's been telling
um Marcus flowers is really good and
sadly I don't think he stands a chance
from the little polling I've seen
Marjorie Taylor green was asked what's
the accomplishment you're most proud of
and she basically says Democrats haven't
let me do anything but I got some grants
and your question from Audrey Taylor
green all right Miss green since taking
office on January 3rd 2021 what is the
one specific accomplishment solely on
behalf of the 14th congressional
district that is most important to you
well I tell you what it's been hard to
pass any bills in a democrat-controlled
Nancy pelosi-controlled House of
representation real real personal
responsibility I couldn't do anything
because of the Democrats kind of i i i a
senate that is controlled by one vote
with Kamala Harris as Kamala the
Democrat vice president and a white
house that is controlled by by democrats
Joe Biden now what we've done to
accomplish things for Northwest Georgia
is I'm proud to be able to bring in
money via grants to help our local
sheriff's department and help local
businesses there we've also worked very
hard with the flooding that happened
over in Somerville Somerville and so
we've worked hand in hand with officials
there and look forward to helping them
more as damages and amounts of money
come out so I'm very excited to to vote
and to introduce bills that uphold the
conservative traditional traditional
values of the people in my district even
her grin seems to suggest she knows this
is BS can you to do that all right Josh
you get the final question did you have
a rebuttal yeah I didn't hear an answer
there ladies and gentlemen
representative green said she's passed
all these bills and brought money into
our district well you haven't you know
no I voted Showbox
okay anyway so just a complete and total
disaster
um one more segment here Marcus flowers
actually a couple this was really
interesting Marcus flowers asked
Marjorie Taylor green why does she seem
to care more about the insurrectionists
than people in her district and she did
not like that you know you spent your
time in Congress these last couple of
years
providing Aid and comfort to the January
6th insurrectionists my question for you
is why do you care more about those
criminals in jail
than you do about the people of our
district you want to know something I
care about about stopping the two-tier
justice system that is happening right
now in America which she thinks is
trumpists and everyone else but the real
two-tier justice system is the
privileged and Elite and everybody else
I was a victim of the January 6 Riot and
I've said it over and over again I'm
completely against what happened on
January 6 but I will not Stand By and
Watch Merrick Garland turn the
Department of Justice into a political
weapon and the FBI sending it after
parents that are addressing their school
boards people that walked in the Capitol
and have been held in jail for nearly
two years while antifa and BLM riots
rioters Go free are never held
accountable now of course that's not
true and the hilarity of a republican
suddenly caring about pre-trial
detention is really really quaint last
clip she does pull out the Q Anon stuff
pedophilia child abuse Etc at party the
Democrat Party is the party of child to
be piece it's the party that represents
grooming children and sexualizing them
in school teaching anti-white racism in
the terms of CRT education and genital
mutilation of kids kids that can't even
get a driver's license can't get a
tattoo and cannot vote how do you stand
there and represent the Democrat Party
as a father and do you believe in
genital mutilation of children under the
age of 18 and and these puberty blockers
that have severe Health consequence so a
really buzzword Q Anon Bingo there from
Marjorie Taylor green she sadly will
probably win and that says more about
the country than it does about Marcus
flowers who is an excellent candidate
we'll take a quick break and then look
at the Ron Johnson Mandela Barnes
interview uh right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
so there's one more debate I want to
look at I wanted to look at the Kerry
Lake CNN interview I promised I would I
just am not going to have time today so
we'll pick that up tomorrow it's less
time sensitive one other important
debate that took place over the weekend
was the one for the Wisconsin Senate
race wherein the incumbent Republican
Ron Johnson is facing a very very strong
Challenge from a former guest on this
program Mandela Barnes and the debate
was very interesting in that Ron Johnson
performed so poorly and so misread the
room and missed the mark that he was
booed and he was laughed at multiple
times during the debate here is a first
segment in which the crowd just laughs
when Ron Johnson says and remember this
is this is Wisconsin okay Ron Johnson
not a border state in the sense that we
think about with the U.S Mexico border
the crowd laughs when Johnson says it
costs us more money not to build that
crazy overpriced wall it's also funny
because Trump is claiming he did build
it so it they're totally incoherent on
this listen to the crowd you do have a
chance
more not to complete the wall that we're
already contracted for that it actually
built
Democrats have voted against three of my
amendments in committee on the floor all
but Senator manchin voted against
completing the wall that we'd already
bought and paid for okay so
um it's not true that we had paid for it
you know allocating money which by the
way was done incorrectly by Donald Trump
appropriating funds you're not allowed
to appropriate for such a project uh but
he's it hadn't been paid for and the
crowd correctly laughing at that very
stupid idea another moment where you
heard audible laughter was when Ron
Johnson claims the FBI set him up by
giving him some kind of fake briefing I
mean it's just conspiracy theory after
conspiracy theory and again the crowd
seems to recognize it and just straight
up laughing at this guy the Ukrainian
people what we want why what we want
they're defending their children their
freedom I think it is good for us
freedom among peoples to hang together
and provide them the defensive Weaponry
so they can defend their territory but
again I want a full accounting and in in
response to the wild charge of
lieutenant governor Barnes the FBI set
me up with a corrupt with a corrupt
briefing and then leave that to smear me
I am
he is referring to corruption with the
FBI which I've been trying to uncover
and expose
yeah I mean you you almost can't help
but laugh other than the fact that this
guy is winning but we'll we'll get to
that in a moment here was one moment
where you just take it and you you do it
the right way
this is the moment at the end of many
debates when the moderators say you know
politics can be so divisive what's
something you admire about your opponent
and it happened during the Hillary Trump
debates in 2016 and I don't remember
what Trump said but I think he held it
together more than than Ron Johnson Ron
Johnson couldn't even just say something
positive take a look at this and the
crowd reacting very negatively all right
we are down to one final question here
and both of you have said a lot tonight
about each other now when we traveled
around the state talking with voters we
heard repeatedly from people tired of
divisive politics and attack ads so our
final question here tonight is both of
you have been successful in life you
have 30 seconds here Mr Barnes you go
first what do you find admirable about
your opponent well no no seriously I do
think you know the senator is proven to
be a family man and I think that's
that's admirable uh you know that's
absolutely to be respected he speaks
about his family he's done a lot to
provide for them I absolutely respect
that
Mr Johnson okay see how that was not
that was unqualified he just said here's
a good thing listen to Ron Johnson and
the crowd just does not like it I mean
likewise I appreciate the fact that uh
lieutenant governor Barnes had loving
parents a school teacher father worked
third shift so he had you know good
upbringing I guess what puzzles me about
that is with that upbringing why is he
turned against America I mean why why
does he find the economy of America
often somehow we did not I said we said
something admirable a total lack of
class and uh disgusting and then later
when Ron Johnson was interviewed on Fox
news about the fact that the crowd
completely turned against him he just
claimed the the crowd was a setup debate
on Thursdays and pieces of it and when
you said you were set up by the FBI the
crowd laughed who was in that crowd and
have they been following the news do you
want to put that in context
well I think they they let in a bunch of
college students so we were supposed to
both get 50 uh
audience members and the crowd was much
larger than that so my guess they're
they're college students who let's face
it our colleges they aren't exactly
teaching history they're really not
talking about you know the relevant by
the way attacking young voters as well
things that students really ought to
learn in college they're they're being
taught leftists of propaganda
unfortunately yeah so one of the worst
debate performances of this entire
election cycle how is the election
actually looking well the the bad news
is that Johnson is winning the good news
is that despite the power of incumbency
Johnson is winning by only 2.8 points on
average and the newest polling is 8 to
14 days old let's see in a few more days
whether this moves there is very limited
time left until that election but we are
tracking it closely it would be amazing
for Mandela Barnes to be able to defeat
Ron Johnson we have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 David P here is a
caller trying to understand what does it
mean I haven't had fast food in 20 years
hey David it's Ross from Vegas I was
watching your live coverage of this
Herschel Walker Russell Warnock debate
yes and you mentioned again something
about not having any fast food in 25
years
does that mean that
you only eat home prepared meals I was
just wondering anyways no no no by no
means when I say fast food I'm talking
about
McDonald's
Wendy's Burger King Taco Bell
some people say Taco Bell those types of
places I haven't been to those types of
places with the one exception of the KFC
incident which I've described before on
live streams I have not been to any of
those places Subway for more than 20
years normal restaurants I go to all the
time but normal restaurants are not fast
food the kind of like the industrial
chain restaurants I have not gone to
that's what I meant okay we have a great
bonus show for you today we're going to
talk about the latest Elon Musk u-turn
on funding starlink in Ukraine really
weird again what's going on California
drivers can now sport digital license
plates on their cars oh boy what does
this mean and we will also talk about
this activist group that threw soup on a
van Gogh painting do I like this as a
protest tactic or not I think many of
you in the audience probably have a
guess all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get instant access by
signing up at
joinpakman.com Great bonus show for you
today otherwise we'll be back tomorrow
foreign